le monde de la culture fixée sur son
sort les salles de spectacles cinéma ou
théâtre nous reverrons pas mardi
prochain une déception immense pour mon
invité on en parle avec lui maintenant
bonsoir jacques vincey bonsoir êtes
directeur du théâtre olympia à tour une
institution une réaction d'abord tout de
suite j'imagine une immense déception un
pad réouverture des lieux culturels
avant le 7 janvier
voyez je dirais d'abord une grande
lassitude et puis tristesse et un peu de
colère je dois dire oui c'est à dire
c'est à dire que je crois que cette
crise s'il faut d'abord le rappeler elle
touche certains dans leur chair et c'est
le plus important et c'est ça qu'il faut
absolument et il faut lutter à tout prix
contre ça elle touche beaucoup dans leur
porte monnaie est évidemment que c'est
important et on sait que ce qu'ont bien
ça creuse et certaines inégalités et que
voilà là aussi il faut veiller
mais je crois qu'elle touche tout le
monde dans son âme sans être
grandiloquent mais je crois que cette
période exige aussi de réfléchir à des
priorités comment on pense pouvoir vivre
demain après-demain traverser cette
crise qui maintenant dur puisque depuis
presqu'un an comment l'art en général
l'art vivant qu'est le théâtre en
particulier peut aider aussi à
mieux vivre à imaginer ce que pourrait
être demain et qui pour le moment pareil
à un brouillard gicquiaud beaucoup de
brouillard qui ne se dissipe plus fait
manquer ce que ça implique dès demain
pour vous au théâtre olympia cette non
réouverture
concrètement ça ça implique une fois de
plus de détricoter ce qu'on avait
patiemment construit vous aviez un
spectacle en avait un spectacle qu'on
devait accueillir le 15 un spectacle
jeune public rémy donc dont le décor
très concrètement devait partir demain
de paris
l'équipe deux jours après donc tout ça
est à remettre en cause les serpents que
j'avais pu créer fin septembre et qu'on
devait jouer les 19 et 20 décembre au
théâtre des quartiers d'ivry pareil
c'est à remettre en cause
voilà et puis encore une fois de plus se
dire bon bah voilà peut-être le 7
janvier on va tout faire de toute façon
on est toujours partant et on fait
chaque fois que c'est possible
on y va depuis le début je ne cesse de
dire que je suis sur la ligne ça va être
possible sinon que d'impossibilité en
impossibilité s'apaisent
derrière le théâtre olympia il a des
salariés des intermittents du spectacle
comment vont-ils faire là dans les trois
semaines qui viennent
comment vous les aider alors je rappelle
encore une fois qu'on est un théâtre de
service public et donc on est
subventionnée pour pouvoir aussi avoir à
une attitude solidaire responsable par
rapport aux gens avec lesquels on peut
travailler et on ne cesse d'essayer de
colmater là où ça ça fuit le plus où
donc du coup c'est le plus les gens sont
les plus précarisés la très concrètement
depuis ce deuxième confinement on peut
répéter dans nos salles on n'a pas le
droit d'accueillir du public mais on
peut répéter donc on a accueilli une
dizaine de compagnies régionales et
quand je dis on les a accueillis c'est
dire qu'on leur a prêté laisser le
plateau la salle de répétition et on
leur a permis de travailler en étant
rétribuer c'est à dire que ça a l'air de
rien mais c'est dans quinze mille euros
qui appelait qui ont été distribués aux
gens qu'ils avaient besoin de continuer
à travailler
voilà laser vers nous pardon voyez je
vous coupe parce que le temps passe très
vite un dernier mot très rapide vous
aviez lancé des actions dans les
collèges etc
pendant le confinement ça ça va
continuer du coup si on le peut oui tout
ce qu'on peut continuer à faire on le
fera et effectivement dans les collèges
on va à la rencontre des des tout jeunes
et c'est important par rapport à ce que
je disais au départ ça fait partie des
choses qu'il ne faut pas lâcher il faut
continuer à pouvoir aller vers les gens
et leur apporter un petit peu autre
chose que cette réalité qui est
tellement sombre merci beaucoup jacques
vincey donc d'être intervenu d'avoir
réagi par rapport aux annonces de jean
castex les théâtres qui ne rouvriront
pas donc avant le 7 janvier